تحدث تغييرات سياسية كبيرة جدًا
هنا في روسيا حيث
تنحى حكومة الدولة بأكملها
ويعمل فلاديمير بوتين
على تسمية واحدة جديدة ،
ما حدث بشكل أساسي هو أن أمير بوتين
عقد خطاب حالة الاتحاد يوم
الأربعاء وفي  حالة الاتحاد تلك
، قال إنه يؤيد
إجراء تغييرات على دستور هذا
البلد والتي من شأنها أن تضعف بشكل أساسي
منصب الرئيس ولكن تجعل
منصب رئيس الوزراء وكذلك
البرلمان أقوى بكثير الآن هناك
البعض هنا من هم  التكهن بأن هذا
قد يكون فلاديمير بوتين
يمهد الطريق لعام 2024 عندما قال إنه سيتنحى
عن منصبه لأنه كان سيصل
مرة أخرى إلى الحد الأقصى لولايته ومن
ثم ربما يبحث عن دور جديد
لنفسه ، ويقول البعض إنه ربما يصبح كأس
رئيس الوزراء مرة أخرى  هذا
غير واضح في الوقت الحالي ، لكن
ما قاله فلاديمير بوتين بشكل أساسي هو
أنه يود أن يرى تعديلاً على
دستور روسيا  في
سيسمح للبرلمان باختيار رئيس
الوزراء ولرئيس الوزراء
لاختيار حكومته الخاصة
وللرئيس يجب أن يوقع بشكل أساسي
على كل هذه التحركات ولكن بشكل أساسي
لم يعد يتمتع بسلطة كبيرة بعد
ذلك الإعلان أو بعد ذلك الخطاب
بقلم فلاديمير بوتين ، استقال مجلس وزراء
دميتري ميدفيديف وميدفيديف بأكمله من
ميدفيديف قائلاً إنه بسبب
التغييرات الدستورية
في ميزان القوى ، فإنه يشعر أنه
بحاجة إلى منح فلاديمير بوتين قائمة نظيفة
لاختيار حكومة جديدة ،
وافق فلاديمير بوتين على ذلك.  استقالة
ثم سرعان ما توصلت إلى خلف
لميدفيديف الذي يشغل حاليًا منصب رئيس
دائرة الضرائب الفيدرالية في روسيا ، وهو
شخص ليس معروفًا جيدًا هنا في
روسيا على الإطلاق ، لكن ما قاله فلاديمير بوتين
هو أنه
سيتحدث إلى جميع الأعضاء الحاليين  من
مجلس الوزراء الذين ما زالوا جميعًا في
مكاتبهم لأنه في دور تصريف الأعمال
ومعرفة ما إذا كان بإمكانهم الحصول على ملف
دور في الحكومة المستقبلية
لإحداث تغييرات سياسية كبيرة تحدث هنا في
روسيا ويبدو حقًا كما لو أن
فلاديمير بوتين قد يكون على وشك
إطالة فترة
تأثيره هنا في روسيا إلى ما بعد عام 2024.